皆さんはエグゾディアというカートご存知でしょうか
このエグゾディアと言うかなど効果を見るとこのカードに加え封印されし者の左足右足
左腕左腕左足右足
左腕右腕が青2店ベルソロ続き勝利が決定する
山拍手ですよ
右腕左腕右足左足がすべて球団揃ったときもうこれぞれた地点でいう企業は勝ちなん
ですよね今回ですねこのエグずやのパーツ5枚とこのデッキを注意しました
でこのデッキ全部合わせて40万円なんですけども休業カードは先行
投稿関係なくてくだ5万円ありますその後枚引いた時点でエクゾディアそう
持っている等も遊戯王カードは勝ちが確定するので今日はこの40ないのできて
エキゾてるカードを5枚に自治体に沿って下って本当に揃うのかどうかっていうのを
ちょっとやってみようと思います
5は40万円のうちの5倍を引けばいい形も各位生産となります
で658,0008分ですか
658,0008分につい
素晴らしいうわぁし
658,0001/8の白龍グッチ
どういう計算す40種 mc 5君の
5 c 5新 face pou dou dou 3%ロスター
オフショット撮っいろよどれだけ時間かかるかわかんないんですけどやはり僕も10円
以上としてずれないことを話します
えけどでよてくだでくるのかどうかというのをやってみようと思います
興味を解除でデッキ紹介ですエクゾディア5枚にブラック町33枚ブルーアイズ3枚
ベッド s 3枚前節のフィッシャーマンハピデジ三姉妹ブラックマジシャンガール3
枚デーモンの召喚3枚人参破壊のゴーレム目じいさんの亡霊紙のカード3枚カース
エンペラーのまあ今すぐフェリーざーを使えない
オートラップです
やっていこうと思います出せばいいでしょう出せばいいいきます
おっても
ただの魂でも一番きたからね志村さんはじめん
あぁそう最初から想定消化こちらから答え対抗みんな
入っていきます
ran ですねん
4大は c
4階に行きます
我屋入ってません
阪神旦那年からよくこれだそうでこれなるようですので切り絵相互ません
7ああおいメディアさあ飛ばすか綺麗じゃなくて
を
声
メディサ月4日あーん
いやね
大
おっはー
小倉フリーでしたら俺がをじっ世界14回目
あっ掘った大
来いよええ
右足とすごいターンほっ
24ダメです
oo
一さん後半だったらドローってやるんですか
あそうだね高校はドローがあるからできます
バー
ran ハーンああああれねこれ
それをくるよヤバイよヤバイよくるよ
ぽっぴっぽー
ポッ
30回目
ドアをワーワー7
気持ちはねこれを追おう
まだだよどうぞ買う前はロロ
これはー
残業前が彼女の中言え読む手取りと税務署
ウェアーっさあ
ああ
ああああああああ
goo
道央
うぇい
はぁヘッダー
仕事しすぎで座ってるん